six chaînes nationales 50 locales les
grandes lignes de la télévision de
demain des signes aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement
invité georges fillioud secrétaire
d'état à la communication il nous
précisera comment ils voient
l'application concrète de ce projet fin
des polémiques eising king fait sécher
vernazza et schuhl se sont rencontrés et
ils aiment ça ils sont de retour les
grands incendies du midi ils ont dévasté
aujourd'hui plusieurs milliers
d'hectares et tué un pompier madame
monsieur bonsoir le gouvernement a donc
fait ses choix en matière de télévision
pour demain en tout six chaînes de
télévision nationale la création de deux
chaînes privées près d'une cinquantaine
de chaînes locales
et puis une chaîne culturelle dont nous
accueillerons les premières émissions
sur le programme national de fr3 c'est
la fin du monopole et l'arrivée en force
du secteur privé dans quelques mois nous
pourrons appuyé sur les 5e 6e voire 7e
et 8e bouton de nos téléviseurs et voir
quelque chose de neuf à quoi ressemblera
ce que l'on appelle maintenant
couramment ce nouveau paysage
audiovisuel dans les mois à venir
eh bien c'est ce que nous allons
découvrir à travers ce dossier le
journal préparé par la rédaction de soir
3 et dont voici le premier élément c'est
celui qui précise les intentions du
gouvernement annoncée en début d'après
midi hubert coudurier
c'est parti le grand show peut commencer
la france va sortir du
sous-développement audiovisuel et les
acteurs se mettent en place
tout d'abord une chaîne musicale qui
couvrira 40 à 60 70 territoires c'est à
dire les grandes agglomérations fait de
vidéoclips et de thunes musicaux elle
s'adresse essentiellement aux jeunes un
projet est déjà sur les rangs celui de
refrains et publicis auquel pourrait
s'associer énergie et la gomme au mais
il ne s'agit que d'un appel d'offres et
ses candidats demandent des garanties
d'exploitation deuxième apparition rtl
télévision qui pourrait prendre en
association avec télé monte-carlo la
tête d'une autre chaîne multivilles mais
moins spécialisés pour rtl télévision
c'est la consécration
cette chaîne est populaire à base de
jeux variété et s'il effectue une percée
en lorraine depuis quelques temps sa
diffusion est tendue par voie hertzienne
est en fait une répétition pour la
compagnie luxembourgeoise de télévision
avant la diffusion du satellite canal +
lui restera que dès la première chaîne
privée à péage connaissant des
difficultés financières n'émettra pas
pour autant en clair comme certains
l'avaient suggéré le redressement des
mois dernier qui ont vu la courbe des
360 mille abonnés augmenter a confirmé
sa vocation le sénat américain pour le
service public pas de changement non
plus sauf pour fr3 la chaîne des régions
accueillera en effet sur ses ondes
certains soirs de la semaine
le projet des groupes de télévision
culturelle européenne avant qu'il ne
monte sur le satellite et des freins en
juillet 86 les trois autres canaux font
pour l'instant l'objet de négociations
ce programme haut de gamme fera la part
belle au théâtre concerts bref à la
création afin de résister à la culture
coca cola il pourrait être associé avec
les projets analogues d'autres pays
européens mais fr3 pourrait également
accueillir des programmes éducatifs à
d'autres heures de la journée où elle
n'est nulle part
reste une dernière nouveauté annoncée en
conseil des ministres quarante à
cinquante télévision locale vers le jour
selon les possibilités du plan de
fréquences déterminées par fait ds et
les autorisations données par la haute
autorité
bref dès 1986 des habitants d'une ville
comme paris disposons de six dont deux
supplémentaires auxquels pourraient
s'ajouter trois chaînes locales reste à
bien
montrer la viabilité de ses projets pour
ne pas passer de la pénurie à l'overdose
et à partir du moment où de nouvelles
télévisions commerciales vont se créer
la question du financement se pose qui
va payer et combien cela va-t-il coûter
qui peut payer pour quoi faire
bref une télévision combien ça coûte
réponse avec ce dossier préparé par
hélène erling scène neuf ménages sur dix
sont la télévision cela veut dire que 16
millions de postes fonctionne tous les
jours qui dit fonctionnement du
programme des programmes audiovisuels
qui coûte cher très cher
tsa budget 85 2,32 milliards de francs
antenne 2 sensiblement le même 2,31
milliards de francs fr3 2,38 milliards
de francs pour la même année
canal+ refuse de donner son budget mais
il a environ 365 milles abonnés qui
paient 140 francs par mois
comment sont utilisés ces budget 60 %
vont directement au programme 40 % pour
les frais de fonctionnement
quant aux prix des programmes pour la
formation un journal télévisé coûte
environ 60000 francs
un journal régional trente cinq mille
francs mais les émissions les plus
chères sont les variétés champs elysées
à la palme 2 millions 500 mille francs
cocorico boy moitié prix
un documentaire d'une heure coûte 600
mille francs
côté sport foot au tennis 99 ans pour
une heure enfin le prix moyen d'un film
un million huit cent mille francs ainsi
quand vous écoutez une petite minute de
télé sachets sont pris entre 8 et 13
mille francs alors pour financer la
télévision ce qu'on a trouvé le mieux
jusqu'à présent c'est la publicité ces
nouvelles chaînes de télévision vont en
grande partie tenter de bénéficier de
ressources publicitaires
il ya tout de même une question la
principale question qui se pose c'est
celle de savoir s'il y aura assez de
budget publicitaire assez d'annoncés
publicitaires pour tout le monde car ce
n'est pas sur ce soir claude guaino mais
pour les télévisions privées pas de
redevance seule ressource la publicité
un gâteau sur lequel veillent
jalousement les autres médias alors y en
aura-t-il assez pour tout le monde
actuellement le tissu publicitaire
français est très sous développée par
rapport à tous les autres pays
développés par le retard est
considérable la sous-médiatisation
française est très sensible
particulièrement sur le plan régional
tu mets les choses devraient changer à
l'horizon 90 les publicitaires très bois
des rentrées supplémentaires de 5
milliards de francs
actuellement le budget de 22 milliards
dont 17%
votre télévision du service public dans
quatre ans ce budget atteindra à 27
milliards
la télévision on observera plus d'un
quart et nouvelles chaînes privées
connaîtront alors le régime de croisière
alors vous le gâteau publicitaire va
s'élargir les nouveaux médias vont créer
de nouvelles recettes publicité tout à
fait on l'a vu dans d'autres pays en
italie par exemple au moment de
l'explosion des télévisions privées
le marché publicitaire s'est développé
une façon spectaculaire et la télévision
bien sûr on a profité en premier lieu
mais même la presse puisque la presse a
recueilli un gars de l'investissement
publicitaire supplémentaire qui sont qui
se sont créés selon les annonceurs les
nouvelles télévisions devrait donc avoir
un effet d'entraînement
bénéfique pour tous les médias les
entrevoit aussi une cinquantaine de
télévision locale là ce sera plus
difficile
les télévisions locales auront un
démarrage certainement très lent et très
difficile nous sommes payés pour le
savoir puisque rtl télévision qui
s'appelait télé luxembourg à l'époque a
connu dix neuf ans de déficit
tant qu'il n'avait qu'un million de
téléspectateurs en lorraine
et ce n'est que quand ça a été repris
dans le câble en belgique que rtl
télévision est sortie du rouge à partir
de 3 millions de téléspectateurs
donc on peut craindre que le
développement des télévisions locales
privées soit vraiment très lent et très
difficile et là dans le schéma actuel
on s'achemine vers un système dans
lequel duras les trois premières plus
une chaîne commerciale grand public les
autres étant des chaînes un peu plus
sectorisé donc ça nous ça nous paraît
tout à fait cohérent et tout à fait
efficace et être la limite mais c'est en
même pas les limites
une cinquième chaîne une chaîne
supplémentaire n'aurait sans doute pas
tenu la route et je crois que le rapport
bredin dans ce domaine était tout à fait
clair
par ailleurs l'apparition de ces
nouvelles télévisions va poser un
problème d'équilibré financier au
secteur audiovisuel mais en même temps
ce sera pour beaucoup l'occasion de
saisir une chance les fabricants de
programmes ou les futurs fabricant de
programmes vont découvrir ce nouveau
marché et de voir le satisfaire nous ne
sommes plus en 63 quand la deuxième
chaîne a été créée ou en 72 quand la
troisième chaîne a débuté en 85
l'arrivée de nouvelles chaînes de
télévision dévoreuse de programme c'est
aussi et surtout une question économique
hélène risacher 10 millions de francs
c'est le ticket d'entrée pour monter une
unité de fabrication de programme un
petit minimum car cette industrie coûte
très cher matériel haut de gamme qu'il
faut remplacer tous les quatre ou cinq
ans afin de rester à la pointe
et puis les fameux 33 % de tva supportée
par l'industrie du programme comme si
l'audiovisuel était encore du luxe
protestent les professionnels à l'heure
actuelle en france seulement 15 sociétés
réalisent d'importants programmes
audiovisuels de qualité parmi elles
l'international network center
fabriquer des programmes suppose des
investissements très lourds lourd au
point que l'intensité capitalistique
c'est un peu compliqué mais c'est à dire
que l'effort d'investissement qu'on fait
pour créer un emploi est supérieur à
celui de la sidérurgie
d'une part que d'autre part il doit être
amorti en trois ans 3 ans et demi au
lieu de parente dix ans pour pour des
industries beaucoup plus lourde
donc vous recevez le l'effort que ça
représente et la france est en retard à
des eaux super machine du trucage
d'image existe à 20 exemplaires dans
notre pays à 150 dans la seule ville de
new york la capacité française de
fabrication de programmes et 20 fois
inférieure celle de la grande bretagne
et il va falloir réagir vite pour n'être
pas envahie par nos voisins européens ou
américains
les télévisions privées tout ce qui est
les nouveaux médias représentent un
marché considérable en matière de
fabrication au programme donc c'est
suppose effectivement le développement
d'une industrie et le développement
d'emplois
encore faudrait-il que
un effort de formation conséquent soit
faite derrière parce qu'ils sont pas des
emplois sont des emplois qui suppose une
technicité relativement importante
technique ou une technicité en matière
jadis électronique mais aussi des gens
qui ont suffisamment oublier la
technique pour laisser exploser la
possibilité de créativité est ce que
c'est c'est toute la difficulté du
métier [ __ ] à la fois des techniciens
mais en même temps des créatifs et c'est
super technicien sont très rares en
france
aucune filière spécifique de formation
existe contrairement à la grande
bretagne ou aux états unis
en somme l'audiovisuel aujourd'hui
offrent de formidables débouchés pour
une main d'oeuvre très spécialisés
encore à venir
il faudra attendre environ un mois pour
savoir quels candidats seront choisis
pour ces nouvelles chaînes
un peu plus longtemps pour les chaînes
locales qui devront présenter des
projets et qu'ils verront un certain
nombre de mach est diffusée sur les
réseaux actuels de tf1 antenne 2 et fr3
ont fait que ses perspectives de
télévision locale passionne bien des
promoteurs un exemple nantes et la
région pays de loire dans la course à
l'attribution des fréquences et un tiers
chacun tente de se placer au mieux
sachant qu'à l'arrivée seuls quelques
uns seront élus le projet le plus
sérieux et man d'olivier guichard à
quatre reprises déjà le député maire de
la baule a demandé l'attribution de
fréquences le conseil régional a même
inscrit ce projet dans son contrat de
plan avec l'état
l'argent est là qui servirait à
alimenter une télé privée dont les
contours restent encore flous sur les
rangs aussi philippe de villiers qui
prend le dossier à l'envers avant de
penser à créer une télé dit il
il faut penser à ce qu'on va diffuser
aussi lance-t-il l'opération gros plan
avec l'achat d'un studio de production
mobile un outil parfait pour alimenter
un réseau en programmes déjà des
connexions semble pouvoir s'établir
entre gros plan et le projet gisha dans
ce dispositif les radios locales les
plus importantes ont aussi leur mot à
dire
georges wolinski le responsable de radio
nantes est déjà en rapport avec un
réseau parisien son projet j'aurai la
carte loisirs avec 24 heures de
diffusion en continu
angers la radio oxygène tente de se
rapprocher du réseau autonome des télé
animée depuis paris par michel fiszbin
même les journaux régionaux lorgne vers
le petit écran ouest france se dit prête
à s'associer à un projet presse océan
aussi par l'intermédiaire de la radio
loire fm qui pourrait se transformer à
l'heure en station locale de télescopes
le réseau hersant qui arrosera la france
entière ce soir les réactions à ce
projet du gouvernement sont très
nombreuses à la fois dans les milieux
professionnels et politiques
le président devait faire trois andré
rouleau s'est félicité du fait que la
vocation régionale et les structures de
la chaîne n'allait pas se trouver
modifiée peu de réactions du côté de la
presse écrite en revanche alors que dans
l'opposition où la privatisation d'une
partie des chaînes de télévision est à
l'ordre du jour bien dans l'opposition
on reste très créateur français que je
connais bien puisque président d'une
association nationale de téléspectateurs
attendaient depuis longtemps un projet
d'élargissement de l'audiovisuel je ne
suis pas de ceux qui demandent la
privatisation totale de la télévision
je crois que l'état doit avoir un
secteur mais je crois que le système
actuel
elle est mauvais et qu'il fallait
profiter de l'occasion pour le revoir
fondamentalement je suis pour tout ce
qui élargit la liberté de choix c'est
clair et je le souhaite depuis longtemps
mais je suis contre vraiment la
procédure qui fait trop de place à
l'arbitraire
je crois que dans aucun pays au monde on
a une telle procédure que dirait ton si
dans quelques mois nous devions
dénationaliser avec la même procédure
que dirait ton si on peut faire ça dans
le secret d'un conseil des ministres
en attribuant telle ou telle entreprise
nationalisée à des copains selon des
règles qui ne serait pas claire et qui
ne serait pas transparent alors il faut
vraiment mettre en oeuvre la
transparence et le pluralisme tel n'est
pas le cas nous semble que comme nous
l'avions
il s'agit bien comme nous avions prévu
il s'agit bien là d'une mise à l'encan
ce et de la soumission à la loi de
l'argent d'un domaine qui est
particulièrement important pour la
démocratie pour la création pour la
culture et en un mot pour la vie
quotidienne tous les français invité de
soir3 celui que l'on appelle le père de
ce projet georges fillioud secrétaire
d'état auprès du premier ministre chargé
des techniques de la communication
alors monsieur le ministre avant de vous
demander de lever le voile sur ce projet
j'aimerais quand même que vous
commenciez par réagir à ces différentes
déclarations de l'opposition
et puis peut être également celle du
parti communiste déclaration dont on a
le sentiment qu'elles sont tout de même
un petit peu critique à l'égard de votre
projet d'abord le voile a été levé
alléché du conseil des ministres de ce
matin quant aux aux réactions je viens
d'entendre je trouve que franchement
monsieur baumel comme chez madelin
exagère
j'exagère beaucoup quand on pense que
ces deux hommes politiques appartiennent
à ces quêtes aujourd'hui l'opposition
mais leurs amis ont gouverné la france
pendant 23 ans ramène trois ans et non
pas ouvrir la moindre petite porte sur
la liberté de communication ni la radio
ni la télévision ils étaient les maîtres
du service public assis sur le monopole
les pdg des entreprises nationales
étaient nommés en conseil des ministres
et voilà que maintenant ils prétendent
nous donner des leçons en disant bien
c'était bien de le faire mais il fallait
pas le faire comme ça et puis après tout
le gouvernement ait choisi enfin soyons
un peu sérieux
quant à monsieur âge s'est exprimé au
nom du parti communiste on sait la thèse
habituel du mob et c'est à dire rien au
privé tout doit être resté une heure
enfermés dans les structures publiques
jeu qu'on peut répondre à cette critique
c'est que justement le gouvernement a eu
dans les décisions qu'il a arrêté ce
matin l'homme souci de maintenir
d'organiser pour le futur un équilibre
entre le privé et le public comme il l'a
fait entre le national et
le local n'est en ce qui concerne l'
équilibre privé public
le gouvernement a pris une décision tout
à fait exceptionnel ce matin puisque il
a décidé d'abonder les moyens du service
public de 700 millions c'est pas une
paille ça résulte de l'abaissement il
vient d'être décidée du taux de la tva
perçue par le fisc sur la relance donc
été jusqu'ici 18 6% et qui va donc
passer l'année prochaine à cette
justement avant de lever le voile parce
que vous vous dites on en a dit beaucoup
on va aller mieux
enfin vous allez nous en dire un petit
peu plus autour de cette table parlons
du financement la redevance pour toutes
ces chaînes va augmenter ou pas elle
reste la même elle à la redevance le
budget pour 86 n'est pas encore
définitivement arrêté mais dès
maintenant je peux vous dire que la
redevance augmentera faiblement elle
augmentera disons durée taux moyen de
l'inflation de l'augmentation des prix
alors à y faire quoi il ya deux choses
qui nous intéresse particulièrement
tout d'abord cette chaîne culturelle
puisqu'on va accueillir une partie des
missions de cette chaîne culturelle un
petit peu avant ou un petit peu après
soir 3 / sur l'antenne nationale
et puis ensuite les chaînes locales
puisque elles entreront directement en
concurrence dans certains cas avec les
stations régionales
alors cette chaîne culturelle ça sera
quoi ce sera une chaîne de télévision ça
sera une entreprise privée ces 700
millions sont tous destinés à la chaîne
culturelle comme comment ça va
fonctionner puis qu'est ce qu'il y aura
on va on va diffuser un opéra on va
diffuser une pièce de théâtre alors
naturellement je suis pas en état
aujourd'hui de vous avez une idée
d'écrire une grille de programmes
ce que je peux dire c'est que ce projet
qui a été étudié par pierre desgraupes
par fonction d'une mission que je lui
avais demandé d'accomplir à partir du
début de cette année c'est un programme
de haute qualité destinée à être
diffusée sur le satellite de télévision
directe à partir de l'automne 86 n'y a
pas que ce satellite aura été lancée
mais tout le monde ne sera pas équipée à
cette heure là
les français mènent les européens c'est
qu'ils pourront de façon progressive en
antenne de réception car le avantage de
ce système de diffusion c'est que ça
permettra de couvrir la quasi-totalité
de l'europe permettra à la france de
parler en français à l'ensemble du
continent européen
avec des programmes de bonne qualité oui
concert tout ce qui constituera
événements culturels dans l'espace
européen c'est donc là un projet d'une
très grande ambition qui permettra à la
france de s'exprimer avec son génie sa
culture ses oeuvres son patrimoine sa
créativité et ses pierres des gros qui
hantera le patron c'est quelqu'un
d'autre
jean pierre desgraupes est chargé d'une
mission d'étude donc il y aura un une un
autre un ordre un organisme spécifique
sera mise en place
mais c'est une mission du service public
donc dans le cadre du service public que
cette initiative se développera et vous
me demandez comment le financement sera
assuré et bien c'est précisément par les
moyens supplémentaires à hauteur de 700
millions d'euros sera financé dans un
premier temps cette opération est à toi
c'est 700 millions seront répartis selon
les besoins de l'ensemble du service
public car il s'agit pas ici sur la
facture a uniquement sur la chaîne
culturelle nous vous parler puisque mais
il s'agit là tensions profondes du
gouvernement de faire en sorte que la
capacité de création production
audiovisuelle française se développe
parce que on imagine bien le formidable
danger devant lequel nous nous
trouverions si on multipliait les
réseaux tiers hertziennes le câble
demain le satellite sans avoir le souci
de renforcer notre outil de production
car si cette heure on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure dans un reportage ou peut-être
nous dire quelque chose sur les chaînes
locales
on sait qu'on n'a pas très bien compris
d'abord sur quel émetteurs et les mettre
dans un premier temps on a pensé que
c'était au moment où il n'y a pas
d'émission sur tf1 antenne 2
r3 et puisqu'on n'a pas compris ainsi
c'est comment elles vont être choisis la
grosse question non alors le schéma est
relativement simple
nous sommes là sous la contrainte de
données physiques ou y at il des
fréquences disponibles pour installer un
émetteur supplémentaire pour une tenue
des réseaux qui couvre déjà le
territoire national alors ça t on sait
que des f&a le document mais aujourd'hui
on n'a pas pu la voir
bon alors vous avez peut-être quelques
lumières led vous dit peut-être
peut-être vous y être êtes vous pris un
peu trop tard mais en tout cas je me
suis assuré auprès de l'étude
mon travail qui n'est pas définitif et
être à la disposition de la presse
poubelle puissent l'étudier bon qui
choisit alors en scène une fois attribué
les émetteurs disponible aux deux
chaînes nationales vous avez parlé c'est
à dire dans les choix semblent plus
grandes villes de france
il ya des villes dans lesquelles il
restera des fréquences disponibles elles
seront offertes à qui voudra les
exploiter ça c'est l'autorité ça c'est
la haute autorité cela suppose une
modification de la loi qui interviendra
pour la session d'automne c'est
l'autorité qui étudiera les dossiers
accordera les autorisations comme elle
le fait depuis deux trois ans pour les
radios locales présent la première
chaîne qu'une de la première chaîne rai
local plutôt privé pourra émettre à
partir de quand elle a les nombreux
délais sont d'une part le temps pour les
promoteurs de préparer leurs programmes
et d'autre part sur le plan technique le
temps nécessaire pour tdf d'installer
les métèques avant le printemps 80
millions j'espère que le plusieurs de
ces initiatives pourront démarrer dès la
fin de cette année ou en tout cas au
tout début de l'année prochaine
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
l'autre décision qui était importante
aujourd'hui prise en conseil des
ministres et bien c'est un mouvement
préfectoral de grande ampleur si on en
juge par les chiffres
trois régions 27 départements 42 hauts
fonctionnaires sont les changements qui
interviennent à sept mois des élections
législatives du mois de mars prochain en
nouvelle calédonie la situation continue
d'être tendu alors que le petit jour va
se lever at you plusieurs maisons ont
été incendiées pendant la nuit par des
inconnus une trentaine de personnes ont
dû se réfugier chez les gendarmes at you
à nouveau paralysé depuis 48 heures par
les actions d'une tribu
les hyènes qui protège l'un de ses
membres soupçonnés du meurtre dif tual
en janvier dernier véronique bonnet
depuis 48 heures les grenades
lacrymogènes répondent aux jets de
pierres les rafales de mitraillettes aux
coups de fusil de chasse
tio est à nouveau paralysé et les
gendarmes ne cessent de s'affronter aux
membres de la tribu saint-philippe o2
kid et ford maurice moi d'où jeune homme
de 19 ans soupçonné du meurtre en
janvier dernier div toile lundi soir en
riposte aux gendarmes qui venaient pour
l'arrêter les indépendantistes bloquent
le pont qui relie la mine de sio à l'oma
quart d'heure du minerai de nickel
légère accalmie puis l'offensive reprend
ce matin avec l'attak de trois escadrons
de gendarmes quatre blindés et six
hélicoptères qui parviennent au bout
d'une heure à lever les barrages tenus
par une certaine de mélanésiens 10 morts
six blessés répartis dans les deux camps
et ce soir le snmkr qui soutient les
habitants de tuyaux appelle tous les
comités de lutte kanaky à la
mobilisation au sud liban une patrouille
israélienne a été victime aujourd'hui
d'une nouvelle opération suicide cela
s'est passé à proximité du château de
beaufort dans la zone de sécurité créé
par israël une voiture bourrée
d'explosifs a touché cinq militaires
israéliens
de plus deux à gauche il est vraiment au
peuple et en parisienne par les
palestiniens
crête sur cette affaire pour le moment
en tout cas c'est une action qui
survient à un moment difficile pour le
gouvernement israélien puisque nous vous
le disions hier un fonctionnaire a été
assassiné en fin de soirée à la pelouse
les esprits s'échauffent et des
dérapages sont à craindre richard tripot
car au fond total barrage inspection
d'habitation l'armée israélienne a pris
position dans la ville de naplouse
immédiatement après le meurtre d'hier
dans cette ville de cisjordanie de 50000
habitants peuplée en partie par des
palestiniens les israéliens ont déjà
arrêté plusieurs suspects et fermer
l'université palestinienne
ces incidents surviennent dans un climat
déjà très tendu après le double meurtre
des instituts en les conviant à pula les
manifestations dans un plat c'est
corrompu aile extrémiste du rabbin kahn
se sont multipliées au cours des
derniers jours
mais aujourd'hui on crie de les arabes
dehors ont répondu les propos mesurés du
premier ministre israélien shimon peres
a en effet déclaré que la lutte contre
le terrorisme devait être menée avec
sang froid et sans réaction hystérique
et il a condamné les châtiments
collectifs l'expulsion des suspects et
la destruction de leurs maisons sont à
ses yeux plus efficace quand jérusalem
il s'agit maintenant d'éviter une
nouvelle flambée de violence tout en
préservant les chances de coexistence
helsinki la conférence continue de
piétiner le seul événement de la journée
a été la rencontre de messieurs
chavernac des échelons
on ne sait pas très bien ce que les deux
hommes se sont dit mais ils se sont
séparés dans l'optimisme si on en juge
du moins par les déclarations qu'ils ont
bien voulu faire tout cela laisse penser
ce soir qu'un premier pas a été réalisée
c'est l'opinion de notre envoyé spécial
mémona hintermann pour passer aux choses
sérieuses aujourd'hui après les
anathèmes d'hier les deux ministres se
sont rencontrés en tête à tête pendant
trois heures de conversation traduction
simultanée
l'équivalent d'une rencontre habituelle
de six heures ont souligné les deux
délégations
un huis clos où tous les problèmes
bilatéraux concernant les deux
superpuissances ont été développées dans
des discussions serrées une atmosphère
franche et cordiale ont-ils fait savoir
mais presque rien n'a filtré côté
américain on affirme qu'il est trop tôt
pour déceler des changements notables de
la politique soviétique
cependant tous les observateurs
s'accordent à dire qu'il y à un
rajeunissement sensible dans le style
des nouveaux dirigeants soviétiques et
dans leur approche des questions
internationales
une impression persiste aujourd'hui plus
personne ne semble prêt à défendre en
priorité la question des droits de
l'homme elle sichi 1985 c'est le retour
à la realpolitik el fekki mémona
hintermann soir 3 dans le sud-est de la
france c'est le retour des incendies de
forêt le début de l'été avaient laissé
penser que l'année 85 ne serait pas
aussi noir que les précédentes
et bien aujourd'hui dans les alpes
maritimes dans le var dans la corse
plusieurs centaines d'hectares ont brûlé
un pompier a été tué et six autres
blessés en corse on vient tout de même
d'apprendre que les incendies étaient
pour le moment maîtrisé par les pompiers
and roll
le feu aux portes mêmes de la ville à
mandelieu près de cannes
une maison a été touchée par incendie et
plusieurs autres ont dû être évacuées
évacué aussi trois copines situés de
part et d'autre de l'autoroute de l'est
hors l autoroute qui a été fermée à la
circulation pendant tout l'après midi
pour laisser l'accès libre aux secours
ce premier foyer qui progressait à la
vitesse d'un kilomètre à l'heure a déjà
provoqué la destruction de 2000 hectares
de forêt à chiffre énorme quand on sait
que ce sont dix sept mille hectares pour
tout le pays qui ont volé l'été dernier
un second foyer s'est déclaré dans le
var mais là les habitations ne semble
pas menacé quoi qu'il en soit 1200
pompiers restent mobilisés dans la
région car le vent qui s'étaient calmées
en fin d'après-midi a repris ce soir
en revanche en corse la situation semble
maîtrisée le temps il sera également
pour quelque chose précisément le temps
demain sera très nuageux le matin sur la
moitié nord ouest de la france avec
quelques pluies au nord-est de la scène
ainsi qu en aquitaine des averses près
de la manche une amélioration se
produira dans la journée
quant aux températures prévue pour
demain vous ai constaté qu elles sont
pratiquement stationnaire par rapport
aux températures d'aujourd'hui cette
édition est terminé demain soir nous
nous retrouvons à 22h05 avant de nous
séparer le rappel des titres de
l'actualité
bonsoir à demain
six chaînes nationales 50 locales les
grandes lignes de la télévision de
demain définit aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement
georges fillioud invité de soir3 les
cinquante chaînes locales privées
débuteront avant le 1er janvier 86 fin
des polémiques à helsinki monsieur
chevardnadzé échoue se sont rencontrés
aujourd'hui
enfin les incendies de retour quatre
incendies importants dans le midi ils
ont dévasté plusieurs milliers
d'hectares et tué un pompier
à